the World Cup is the most viewed
sporting event in the world the 2010
World Cup in South Africa was shown in
every single country and territory on
earth including Antarctica and in the
Arctic Circle 3.2 million people watched
that's forty six point four percent of
the world's population this is the first
Cup in 1930 more than 34 million fans
have attended 772 World Cup matches
making for average attendance of around
44,000 fans per game 2014 will be the
20th World Cup it will be held in 12
stadiums across Brazil this summer 32
teams will compete in 64 matches the
World Cup national teams will get at
least 8 million dollars each to compete
and the winning team will take home 35
million dollars Germany has promised all
23 players of 407 thousand dollar bonus
for capturing the title the famous
Brazilian player Ronaldo holds the
record for the most goals scored at
World Cups with 15 Landon Donovan has
scored the most World Cup goals for the
u.s. 5 Americana Stadium and Rio is the
site of this summer's final game it is
the largest stadium in Brazil as a
seating capacity of 70 3531
the host country has a good chance to
win the cup and it wouldn't be the first
time Raziel has made more appearances at
the World Cup 19 than any other team and
Brazil has taken home the trophy five
times other repeat winners include Italy
with four wins and Germany with three
you